[Music]
so yeah I mean this has been quite the
process the tanks were delivered over
land this winter and now they're in
place painted hoses in the right area
just did the electric pumps put
everything in the whole thing is new and
it envelopes more than a solid year of
work but it's done this is the beginning
this is the leading edge of my busy time
the impression that I get that I give to
people when they fly over and they see a
clean comfortable put together place you
cannot buy that that first impression it
has to be something they get I have to
have a profitable business in order to
keep living here this is going to help
me hey there Baba well this is it
there's no more on there's no more big
motor sitting in here this is all I got
to do I got the transfer switch outside
but it's the jet fuel here the hundred
low LED here and wait for it it's
running you don't hear a darn stinking
ping that's pretty cool we can take a
bucket out let me go get a diaper and
we'll take a bucket out just to verify
that we got clear blue coming out look
at that oh yeah they're nice and blue
right blue hundred go ahead yeah is that
acceptable yep looks good it's a little
surreal to me there's no noise the brain
that tells and tells me it's a auditory
clue that the fuel is running this is
just there's no noise at all you can
barely hear the hum of the electric
motor yeah this is what it's all about
he's putting it in the plane and he's
gonna fly off and get home safely
very first feel sale go me on the new
system it's very quiet it's very
efficient like Bob said twice as fast on
the delivery accurate as heck good and
clean it's everything I want in the
business to offer to somebody for this
area this is on par with Thomas Edison
inventing the light bulb and getting rid
of the gas
right there what you hear in the
background you can throttle up get in
the air and go home safely
[Music]
[Music]